i share my screen
go for it over to you ben
thanks so much right let's see if this
works
can you tell me we can see the no
there we go ben whether you can all see
that is that okay
brilliant stuff thank you so much we
would
looking at this a bit earlier on and uh
it's a bit gloomy isn't it i'm sorry i
know they're much much better pictures
of
of torrington this is one i took when i
was down the first time
uh but i have since been down the second
time and met a number of you
um for the second time so really nice to
see some familiar faces and thank you
um very much for coming and and chris to
you
for that introduction um
so what we're gonna do we've got an
agenda
for today as chris has said it'd be
really really good if we can be as
discursive as possible
um we've disabled i think the q a
function but chat's completely available
for you to use
it would be really good if you use that
or or as chris says just dip in
if you find by the way i'm very happy
just have that discussion
um those of you that don't know me a
quick bit
of my background so um i have been
um in the sort of place making
plays professionals game for about 20
years now
um i had a sort of background in
working in london but i now work all
over the country to support all sorts of
different places and particularly
with the recovery from covert at the
moment um
i've got uh interest particularly in
local economies
um in i used to run a successful street
food market
um i worked quite a lot in neighbour
planning so
those of you that understand and that
prepared neighborhood plans
um you'll know what i'm talking about
and also i'm on the government high
street task force which is really about
um helping high streets across the uk
recover
um they've done the housekeeping
um we're gonna yeah there's gonna be
particular times when we ask you to
pitch in uh
for particular things but as i say just
jump in as you
want um the agenda for today
um uh so i'm just gonna
talk talk about uh places in general and
five things i've learned
in my experience from uh places um and
then
i wanted to do a bit of a recap of the
vital and viable work that we did
um through the institute for place
management last year i'm not actually
here in that capacity this time
um but certainly what we're trying to do
is follow on from that vital and viable
work particularly as we're
looking um back to the favorite recovery
that economic recovery for
base and then we're going to look at
um some of the sort of stats around
coinvirus and what's changed
um how other places are managing uh
recovery
uh will ask you a few questions about um
how
your sort of personal shopping habits
and how people are doing in the town
and some of the barriers to success um
and then the action planning process
itself so so
the output of this is a very very quick
and dirty you know where i speak for as
many people as i possibly can and these
are the things that i think
can be achievable and i'm really hoping
that it's not going to be too
controversial um
maybe a bit of controversy isn't such a
bad thing but the idea is that we have a
discussion about what isn't
and isn't achievable this isn't the only
one i'm doing i'm also looking at
biddeford and i'm
also looking at holesworthy so um so um
there will be some similarities and
differences so
just before we get started does anybody
want to pitch in anything or
or should i just dive on in
and also chris if you can monitor the
who's got
hands up and stuff and just stop me if
people have got hands up because i can't
actually see that i mean
john i'm just wondering if we got a time
scale for this meeting because if we
haven't it could go on forever
and we're running until eight o'clock
it is our absolute maximum john but
we're hoping to get out before then
perfect thank you very much okay
okay so just yeah i just wanted to talk
uh uh talk about places
in general and five things that i've
learned about places that might help the
discussion a little bit um
just to frame it um the first one
and i think you know it's quite an
important one is that is that all places
all towns are unique
um and i think one of the things that we
have seen recently
well certainly over the last 20 years
this idea of the clone town the idea
that
um where basically every place started
to look the same from
from the 1990s there's a lot of
expansion aggressively into places
lots of pains uh all appearing in the
same sort of places and
sort of a risk aversion on the part of
landlords and
and and i think one of the things that's
been really interesting
to note about uh the towns of north
bevin is they've been quite shielded by
that
and we've seen um some signs that
uh the independents are a lot more being
a lot more supported these days
um and really where where
there were too many chains people
weren't being attracted into town
centers so actually
uniqueness is a is a really really
important thing for places and it's it's
something that i've totally seen across
the board north devon
and i think also where you have places
that all look the same
that's really driving people to out
places driving people
shopping so um this resurgence of the
independent is really really important
um
i think it's not when i talk about
uniqueness it doesn't just come from
shopping as well i think
places are becoming more attractive
because of a whole range of
activities so things like events and
festivals
markets i was talking about before the
evening economy
you can you can provide your place
with a sense of uniqueness using all
sorts of different techniques
and providing all sorts of different
amenities um
and i'm sort of seeing that wherever i
go is that that's what's really helping
places get better the second thing is
is this idea that change is inevitable
and necessary and i think
it's i've seen a lot of places lose
their way particularly places that were
very
associated with particular kinds of
industry or activities
and those those then started to decline
and i think it's really really important
that
that people understand that where places
feel like nothing ever changes
actually places are always in flux and i
think some people that are speaking to
in in the in the towns i've visited
north devon so far
um you know they sort of say the town's
gonna survive and they're absolutely
right
um i think the issue was really that
things is
going to be necessary for the town to be
sort of sustainable in the long term
and that's sort of why i'm i'm doing the
job that i'm doing
um if it's just left to its same devices
actually what we'll see is a sort of
flow economic decline particularly
around retail
and although you don't have to do
anything about that it just means fewer
jobs for younger people
your amenities for you as townsfolk
and and you know sort of without a plan
it just means you know there's there's
no sort of
there's no focus on where you're headed
as a place and i think that's quite
important
so time's a bit of change and that's
sort of what the plan is about
um the third thing this is this uh john
f kennedy quote is really about
illustrating the importance of
collective action and personal
responsibility and i know that the
people here are in a sense got kind of
self-selecting in the sense that
you will work really hard to bring about
change in your places
um and i think
as much as possible if people can be
encouraged to
think about what they can do rather than
how they can be
how they can be um uh sort of supported
by others
um it's you know it's i guess what i'm
saying is the places that i've seen
really change over time
are the ones where people have really
sort of stepped up and made those
changes themselves and i know that
somewhere like torrington
is it is sort of fantastically supported
by a great volunteer network and
you can sort of only do so much um but i
suppose
what will go in the action plan is a
real mixture of the sort of
infrastructure projects that the council
can do
but also some of those things that can
happen locally um at your behest
um i think you know this is sort of
connected but there's this whole idea
that not
not everyone cares about where they live
and and
and that's that's okay and i think again
those people that that are on this call
you know they're again they're sort of
they're they're very clear that they
care about the places but you shouldn't
beat yourself
up i suppose if you're not able to
convince absolutely everybody to get
involved in
in the place um and you know as much as
we would like
that to be the case you know people can
be quite self-interested in it
at times and sometimes it's not you know
it's not everyone
working together it's been a real
learning curve for me to understand that
in my job but just you know this isn't
people are busy there's all sorts of
reasons they can't
um get involved um
and then the last one is is that the
whole thing that you can absolutely do
nothing
if you want to um and and i think
there are you know there are all sorts
of things to learn from places that
would choose not not to create a plan
and there's all sorts of things around
you know sort of half day closing that
happens in in different places and
and some people just don't don't want to
swap you know their
wednesday afternoon just for that
additional bit of profit and and
and that's also okay and we see that
happening
in a lot of different places i guess the
point is that if we're trying to link
that idea of demand and supply
you know for tourists for locals and for
all sorts of different people that are
coming into the town
and um we have to have quite frank
conversations with that with
with ourselves about you know where the
plan is and what the plan is to sort of
meet those needs
um now if i could just if before we just
open it up a bit i just wanted to recap
what we learned last year so we did this
swot analysis um strengths weaknesses
opportunities and threats and i just
wanted to concentrate specifically on
the opportunities because what what we
want to do in this call
and in the action plan is really focus
on on the future rather than
talk about the problems of the past so
and just to run
through them really quickly in terms of
opportunities
there's this whole idea in in in
torrington that that
there needs to be a much more sort of
joined up approach particularly
physically
between the different amenities and
assets you've got some of which are
slightly out of plans
in rosemoor the parker trail the commons
um you know these ideas of trails and
sculptures around the town i think it
is really interesting one and something
that may uh may or may not still be
um really important as we come out of um
out of lockdown again you know that idea
of capitalizing on volunteers
um you know really strong volunteer
network
um i think capitalizing is one word
celebrating is another you know they're
not just a sort of endless immunity that
they can sort of be drained dry and i
know
that some of you might feel like that
yourselves where you know everything
always feels like it's left back to you
if there's a really strong volunteer
network it's something that can also be
built on
uh and something that can really make it
make a change um
uh for torrington um
i know we've got a lot of people with a
lot of opinions here um
very keen to hear from people as well so
these are just so
uh i've just got one more slide which is
the rest of the opportunities and then
we're going to be
ignoring even if that's all right so
many opportunities
and so yeah so there's this idea of the
common vision and then
uh we've talked about i know that that's
controversial but that idea of
shared space and pedestrianization and
then
for all of these you can read them for
yourself and i know that you'll be
asking who organizes these things and
how does this work um but uh
but this is the list basically and the
question that i want to ask you now is
is this list still correct
um particularly sort of economically
things have changed quite a lot in
torrington
um what else is lacking in the town
you know has things changed in that in
that respect and then thirdly
is there anything that you think needs
to change for the town to thrive
sort of going forward into the future so
that
brings us to the first bit where we open
it up to you does anybody have any
thoughts would you like to raise your
hand karen
let me just say um ben um since january
in fact we are very much in embryonic
stages but the town council is launching
in a marketing
working group and we've got our first
meeting on the 30th of september
and really with with that we're looking
at
um we're looking at the environment
heritage
culture independent shop and sport and
leisure
and i think one of the quick wins it
won't be quick
because you know nothing's that quick
but we're looking at maps
you know we have no maps and trails we
have no maps of um
walks we have very you know so again
there's some stuff we can do quite
relatively quickly and then another note
is it i have an interesting discussion
today with somebody about the changing
work
practices nationally yes and and one of
the things we were talking about
is that you know people who've always
had to live near cities
may not need to live near cities to be
able to work
and the property prices down here are
relatively cheap
compared to if you're buying a property
in order shots my friend's about to sell
hers for about four
no about twice as much as you get down
here for the same
so you know there's sort of one eye on
the future in that
very much off you know hot off the press
is that the changing work culture that
we're seeing
you know sort of come come forth now
post covered could actually also
significantly affect demographics as
well with the town
and how particularly that daytime
population that sort of
to have that daytime spend in the town
really can change things and actually
when i've been to see some of the estate
agents in some of the other northern
towns i didn't
manage to actually find one in in
torrington
but they said that they've been they've
had lots of
um inquiries from people from much
further field than they ordinarily would
the people looking to move into north
devon so i think you're absolutely right
karen
that's that's sort of like on the cusp
of the wave isn't it really that sort of
happened since january
yeah the whole you know that's the
national picture so it's just all of
those things
but the marketing group we're meeting
for the first time in a couple of weeks
and i would imagine we're inviting
people onto that group anyone who's got
an interest in
those particular areas we're really
looking for skill base
um so yeah so we're hoping that that
could sort of help with some of these
issues that maybe we're going to discuss
as we go forward as well that's exciting
thanks
john you had a comment
indeed i do um i'm aware that most of
the people who work hard
for torrington in torrington are
probably already there
doing it uh most of us are not
unsurprisingly quite weary from having
thrown our weight behind doing
quite a lot of things in torrington over
the years and you see the same faces
on a constant basis leading these groups
and it's the leading in the group that
we are short of people
to actually cover that ground
i think it will help it would help
everybody but
the one thing that is always outstanding
is the investment part
we all have great ideas and we all have
thoughts of what we can do with it
but none of this will ever be happening
if it's not predicated on the fact we
actually get investment
to actually push them forward uh and i
think a lot of people
are a little bit wary of trying to get
involved in these things because they
don't know how to get the money
hey and they don't know if there's any
money available and not not many people
will also understand where that money is
going to come from either
and it's always been the biggest problem
is how to get your hands on some of the
money
and quite simply the entire time could
do with just somebody
who just fills out funding forms the
entire time and can actually
relate to the issues that the leaders
the one of a better word take to the
table and seek out the
funding that is necessary to actually
build on the base
john can i come in at this point i think
the crucial point is that funders don't
fund projects that aren't part of a
strategic picture um and
so if we're just talking about
disjointed something here something
there
they're not going to buy in we need and
this is part of
why we need to be doing these um
workshops to make sure that actually we
are drawing more people in
we are listening to more people that
we're getting more engagement
and not just having the same people who
feel
wow was i that strongly worded um
but we do need to make sure that we've
got more people
so that people don't feel well it's just
going to be the same old same old
and that might mean doing the occasional
radical thing and trying things out
but that has to be based on
conversations like this anyway
any other thoughts on some of those
opportunities that
ben shared
richard just a quick one i i think the
pedestal the
um pedestrianization of the the main
square from you know at certain times
during the day allowing for deliveries
and things could be
could be really positive i just think
he's he's got mileage
richard and not meaning to put you on
the spot feel free to not answer this
um but from a plow perspective if say
there was pedestrianization after
2 pm on a saturday would that create an
opportunity for the plow
uh yeah possibly it might mean that if
we
if we have the cafe back open by then
and we've got a busy live event in the
evening and it's summer that we could
offer food outside on the street you
know i mean it's interesting
the way you know under covered isn't it
it's interesting seeing
cafes and restaurants um the way they've
sort of basically taken over the roads i
i was in
upper wrist with last couple of weeks
ago and they closed off the whole city
center
and had sort of uh council stewards
making sure that people you know didn't
sort of drive up those roads and all the
restaurants and cafes just spread out
onto the road
and and i remember walking around
thinking that this could stick you know
because it didn't seem to be an issue at
all
and they they reopened the road
strangely at six o'clock in the evening
but during the day
or between ten and six they were
actually the main streets in aberystwyth
were all closed and all the cafes and
restaurants
spread out into the road and it was a it
did have a genuine kind of continental
feel it was great i think my perspective
is very much
um this is very much a conversation
starter rather than
a conversation end that the the time of
the year that people in torrington love
most
is mayfair which is the time of year
that we shut the square off
and allow people to actually kind of
enjoy
that square in a safe um environment
i think we know that it's not
necessarily going to work all day every
day
but is it what do people think about
kind of
opportunities to experiment around that
i i can see john's hand up i'm keen to
hear from some
other people as well but we'll go we'll
go for john to start out with
um i i've always threatened the fact
that pedestrian nation
pedestrianizing torrington was something
that need to be
baby steps but it's something that we
really should look at sensibly on a time
scale that'll work for
the community and the businesses uh and
and to see if there's any common ground
i fully appreciate the issues in
business
and how they will see pedestrianization
but i don't think it's until we try it
as a trial
we're going to find ourselves unable to
actually visualize what the outcome is
going to be
exactly innovation based on
experimentation and creating
data and response
fantastic right councillor bright
welcome
um i'm hoping this is suggesting that uh
cnr has finished before seven o'clock
which is a very positive sign
um any other thoughts or
comments on that ah jill
i'm just checking on not muted yet no
you're coming through
um i think the i mean when we talk about
pedestrianization there is quite a bit
of negativity comes across but i think
one of the things we could do is trial
it and maybe even just have one
night a week where we start with sort of
baby steps regarding pedestrianization
i was sitting in the square on friday
doing a football and somebody came up
and said i don't know why we don't have
this
square pedestrianized and then people
can sit out and have coffees and
stuff and uh and i said yeah you know
we've we've sort of mooted it but it's
there's not that doesn't seem to be that
many people in favor
at the minute and they were adamant that
they thought it was a great idea so i
think there is a bit of a mixture so
maybe if we trial it and then perhaps
think about having maybe one night or
afternoon and
early evening with perhaps if there's a
big plow event on where we do
do that that might work well i mean i
wonder richard if we have a
conversation at some point about whether
there could be an outdoor event at some
point in the next couple of months
we'll ask the community what they feel
and see what can be done
but we can carry that one on as a side
conversation
charlotte were you waving your hand
there i was um hi chris i just wanted to
one of the problems that we have in
torrington is that there's nowhere to
actually eat in the evening
um and obviously richard suggested that
maybe you know once the plow reopens
maybe that might be a possibility
um but that would be the biggest draw i
think
for most people to actually want to come
in and spend
time in a pedestrianized area is to be
able to eat out but
there's a lot of you know closures at
the moment like the black horse is now
closed
obviously the cafes generally aren't
open in town at the moment
so i think we need to try and think
about how we could draw
people in from a food perspective
perhaps
i i would agree um wholeheartedly um
i would also encourage people to note
that in the chat
function i've put up a web
link which starts with which bit dot l y
forward slash
the globe torrington um that is case
sensitive
uh so this is an online form that i
launched earlier today
basically asking people's thoughts about
the proposals
that have come forward from torridge
great torrington town council petroc and
the plough arts centre
to bring forward a community acquisition
of
the globe and its points are that
charlotte
about the fact that we do need a
stronger nighttime economy
we do need jobs which i mentioned
earlier by ben to actually get
the town centre moving and more
importantly working for as many parts of
our community
as possible so yeah so if we can all
complete that one and share it
to everyone we can think of then that
would be hugely appreciated please
okay right i think
i'm gonna hand back to ben
yeah right hey
does anybody have any further thoughts
they want to raise just to say that
to bring people in you as well as you
need the places open to be able to have
a continental coffee or
something to eat you know what about
something like a film night
you know you have an outdoor film i
don't know but we do need something
going on
if we're going to try breaking ground
and experimenting
i think it's good to forgot to
experiment in some shape and form but
it's a balance between
and that's where you know we need the
chamber of trade involved in this or the
you know the businesses around the
square as well so i'm sure there's room
to
for the two to run together is it fair
to say that
that there aren't any particular
downsides to pedestrianization
after a certain point in the day i mean
most of the businesses are closed by
what five
at the latest
[Music]
doing all sorts of different things in
the evening it's just a question of who
organizes them i suppose
yeah yeah i think evenings it goes i
mean council clayton's been doing some
football and it was quite surprising
how many people were still walking
through the town even though the shops
weren't open
so i think yeah i think that's pretty
good i'm aware over to
and john burrell please
so hi guys as a a newcomer to the town
and okay here a year ago i think it's a
fabulous place
i absolutely love it i moved from west
yorkshire quite the distance
i think the town square is such an asset
and we've seen lots of other towns
that it's just crying out for some level
of pedestrianization
not all the time but certainly evenings
or a weekend or special events
it just makes me my heart believe that
it doesn't happen
but we've lived in unusual times at the
moment but please do it it's
just great that that could be one of the
quotes of the evening john
do we have anybody on the call who who
is absolutely
just completely against it in one way or
another
i want to venture to put the hand up
no that i mean that's good and that's a
bit of a vote of confidence that
something might be tried
um but it sounds to me as though
certainly talking to businesses
that it needs to be very very
sensitively done and i think baby steps
is absolutely
is actually right in that case um
right let me move on and so i just
wanted to talk
about what has happened with ronavirus
and how things have been changed over
over the time that we've been
um working on this this project and so
obviously this is not a a picture that's
particularly surprising
um you know we've seen a lot of store
closures over the time interestingly
um working in torrington it doesn't feel
like too much has closed although
certainly even the economy is done
slightly bucking the trend but even the
economy is slightly worse than the shots
um but when it comes to job losses in
the shops
um you can see that uh over time
uh that the uh sort of projected job
losses
uh and also store closures we're going
up actually
what what's predicted um for 2020
2018 117 000 job losses predicted now
235 in 2020
i think that's actually a pretty um
likely to be quite conservative estimate
um for
2020 and i think also
one of the things that we haven't we
sort of don't understand yet looks like
eat out to help out it's been an
enormous success nationally um one of
the things we haven't
seen yet is sort of as furlough comes to
an end it might be that we might not see
too many store closures but we will
certainly see redundancies and there's
questions over that
again questions to ask over what that
means
for torrington it feels to me as though
it's been quite
uh resilient over time but let's see
what happens
and just in terms of the sort of main
factors that i think particularly will
also affect
uh torrington i mean hospitality
in terms of i mean i know that you don't
have hotels which is
partly the sort of big drive behind um
behind the globe um but hospitality has
been in trouble for
for quite a long time and particularly
interesting spiraling
uh rents labor shortages that sort of
thing
but when it comes to designing what
happens with the globe
you need to think very carefully about
how you know how that will be structured
who will work there
um and what are the sort of broader
activities that can go around it and i
think in particular
you know that there are there are
several um sort of
main asset in the town there's the plow
there's the globe there's the community
hall
um and i think a sort of concerted plan
for those to work together would be
quite important
actually for their uh assured
and social infrastructure is another
really interesting one um it
would appear that there's going to be a
lot less money to
help um cope with some of the you know
the issues adult social care
homelessness
of really um raised their heads over the
last few months
but at the same time we're seeing a bit
of a resurgence in the notion of
community and i know that you've seen it
locally
we've certainly seen it nationally too
with some really big initiatives that
are that are really
getting off the ground locally for
people to help each other even if it's
just knocking on your neighbor's door
somebody that's shielding somebody
that's running well and just just sort
of helping them out
um karen you were talking before about
that
change in work patterns um i think
you're absolutely right with that one
you've got a lot more people working
from home uh
in a place in all places in the uk from
the smallest towns
uh to the biggest suburbs and
it will be very very interesting to
understand how
particularly as companies become more
cash strapped over time
if officers are downsized what could
that mean
for our communities will people be
working from
home actually will there be more local
work clubs
so places in town that people can work
what does that mean in terms of
you know local economy sandwich shops
things that will support that sort of um
that use in town centers um
there will be interesting changes to the
population
um uh i mean maybe a bit less so in
terms of north dakota
but we will see changes to the
population as a result of
both at the higher and the low end uh
the older and the younger end i should
say
and then finally i mean north devon
certainly tourism is is a key part of
the economy it's not the only
part of the economy but north devon is
pretty much dependent on
a functioning airline industry and
tourism
for quite a lot of its jobs um
be really interesting to understand and
you know i hope not too tragic but
interesting to understand what the loss
of the 2020 season
is going to look like um whether
businesses will be lost as a result now
i've seen certainly in a number of
places i've been working in that the
summer season with
vacationers um has been a lot more
successful than than
maybe some anticipated so some of your
thoughts on
that and and how i i know you don't have
tons of floors some of your thoughts how
things have been working
in that respect uh would be interesting
to
nate after this section um
so uh let's talk a little bit about how
places are managing recovery because
there are
some ideas in here that might help you a
little bit
um so places like uh kendall
northallerton
and soltaire they're doing some quite
interesting stuff around the virtual
high street
and there are apps now available um in
places that
have you know shopping centers um or
or high street which attention
essentially just take that high street
online
enable you to be able to click and
collect so if
there are a number of different shops
that are participating
it in it then you would be able to order
your shopping online
um and then you'll be able to that would
essentially
be delivered to you or you could just um
sorry christmas that's right
that's okay i was gonna um felicity's
joined just
exactly the right time um
i couldn't get on to the don't worry at
all um
but it'd be great to get you nice to see
you
it'd be great to get you and ange's
opinion on something like this
so um shop happy as ben said
um is something that actually we've been
looking into along with a couple of
other platforms
and effectively it's a
site or an app that brings together all
of the stores
in torrington as an example um
so you could all have an online presence
through this app so anyone in the local
community knows
right i want to buy something locally
online
um from torrington
and it creates an online store for all
of you
some of the uh options enable you to
then
create a central place for people to
come into the town and then collect
all of their order from various
different shops
in one foul does that sound interesting
does that sound convoluted
what would your initial thoughts be
um just to jump in the karen it's also
probably worth
you knowing that um i mean they're
they've all got slightly different
uh focuses and loyal free is really good
on trails and sort of
it does really interesting things around
sort of tourism and you know getting
people to understand the heritage of the
town as well as
sort of retail side of things so so
they've all got slightly different
um focuses
oh there is karen yeah felicity
any thoughts on that kind of uh an
opportunity
i mean i think for our business
which you know if somebody wants to pick
up a i don't know a
massive great chest of drawers or
something and obviously there's sort of
logistical
you know difficulties around that
but would it be useful for for example
um to have a place where as a new item
of
um sort of comes into the shop that you
could very simply
post it onto this portal anyone in
torrington could have a look through and
go
oh yeah you know what i really like that
or would you
fear that people would have a look
on the online portal and then go
oh actually i don't need to come into to
the shop to browse
yeah i think our shop in particular is a
browser
a browsy place um
you don't know what's there sort of and
to photograph things
crikey that would be a full-time job in
itself i think
okay yeah um joe um my other half does
a lot of that with facebook anyway um so
every week
we put a facebook post on
to show what new stocks in um if
people we have a lot of them people that
sell through us so we
update their the things that they've
been doing and making and
creating as well um so we sort of do
that every week anyway
um i mean i think if it
as as felicity said because of the kind
of
things that we sell in a way we sell
kite sort of similar things in the sense
that you know we do do big furniture but
we do
small gifts as well um we've done some
posting of gifts during
coronavirus um but other than that
we do a lot of deliveries you know
people come in and buy
a table we deliver them so um
it sort of it might work for some of the
shops but i don't think it would work
for all of them it is
i think what we've kind of coming to
yeah
android completely it's it's the
interesting thing about so we've got
various different people who are uh like
yourself selling through facebook
it's then a case of right well how do we
make sure
and this could be a solution it might
not be i'm
not certain myself and how do we make
sure that
everyone from across torrington can find
one place
to find all of the the people who are
selling
rather than going right i need to go
over here to find that person
yeah and they're on facebook but i'm
going to find someone else who's on
etsy and someone else is selling through
instagram
and and it's that variety of platforms
that then creates the
potential confusion um yeah see what you
mean yeah
yeah um yeah so somewhere that
you can just go to one place and from
there you can see
that there's this there's this there's
this there's this
absolutely and then you might decide
okay i'll go and have a look there
um yeah i mean that that would work
whether or not
being able to sell through that
particular portal
would be as possibly over complicate
things but maybe it could be
just to provide the information again
this is where it's best to have these
conversations and we find the right
things eventually so
okay yeah yeah karen shifting to you and
then i'm aware that mr ashford
when i saw when you said about the
virtual high street you know the the
estate agents are doing virtual viewings
right now well i was sort of thinking
because what we've done the last we're
going to do it again in october we've
got a list of all the different types of
businesses that are in the town
that go out and cry but i was thinking
something like could you do a quick
snappy
like virtual visual tour of the town
i mean if you if you if you if you focus
into collectibility it gives you
a straight away a vision of what that
shot's got it's packed with lovely
things if you
and whether or not you could then make
that quick and snappy
for a great time and this is what these
are these are shots that are on offer
but visually rather than just listing
the different shots
if it was interesting i could have a uh
we have a local
um and very young dynamic excellent um
360 degree photographer
and who's just taken some amazing
footage of
uh our future high street fund site in
biddeford
who does actually offer a very very very
reasonable rate
to come round um to
retail um one of the things we're
looking at
for example because one of the things
we're looking at is a town map anyway
maybe local artists listening shop but
if you can visually see what's in the
shop
you know the the shop is eleven eight no
is it eleven no the one in the market
it's all the different numbers sorry um
i mean you just gotta look in there and
it takes your attention straight away
because there's lots of things in there
so if you could just
snapshot each shop and business that
there isn't
that would be you know an opportunity
for people to do a virtual tour of
what's available in the town centre
and the pani market just just an idea
really but the interesting chris
the details of that person yeah and
hamish
has been working on it but he's um
unfortunately off at the moment so yeah
felicity i'm going to come to in a sec
i'm aware that mr asherford
uh has got his hand up and i'm guessing
he's going to talk about the one
turrington website
that's what i was going to say yeah yeah
exactly yeah that's that's what i was
going to come on to
so we launched the one great torrington
dot uk website
back at the beginning of june and
that has got the opportunity for shops
and
local groups and societies etc to put
their listing online they can upload
photos of their shop and their wares or
whatever they might be doing
so the opportunity is there we could egg
with a small pot of money expand that to
include the virtual tours
which i know karen has referred to in
others so there is scope to build on
that website
um as we venture into the future
okay would it be possible to get uh
people's
kind of as we said at the moment we've
got people selling through facebook
through etsy through all sorts of
channels um
is that something that the moment you've
been pushing people to provide as well
yeah so each each listing will have
obviously the contact details the
description
photos and links to social media
whichever platform they might be on
any or all fantastic
ian those people who haven't come across
the site could i ask you to please just
put that
into the chat as well so that anyone can
access that
uh in just so you're aware this uh it is
being recorded as well
so these kind of things hopefully can
get out to as many people as possible
moving forward right
well that was an interesting discussion
um
any final comments on that one before we
hand back to ben again
richard one um it might seem kind of
counterintuitive that we could do things
online but
we are thinking as part of social
distancing if we can reopen with limited
audiences for live events within the
player
for on and for films that well mainly
for live events we could stream them at
the same time so we're looking to
try and get capital funds to to get the
cameras and so on and the extra
technical expertise
so that people who don't want to risk it
in inverted commerce
could stay at home and perhaps order
some food from takeaways in torrington
et cetera et cetera can we link to it
or um and a small audience will pay to
uh to risk it and watch it live within
the plan
you mean to enjoy the atmosphere of the
wonderful plow arts center
indeed absolutely okay no i mean it
it does sound counterintuitive to a
certain extent
but we all know that we need to be
looking at different opportunities and
diversify
and it's the places that are
diversifying that have been the ones
that are successful
i think torrington's already shown a
great example of that with the town hall
um taking on the sunday lunches and the
steak nights from
the black horse to just make the most of
opportunities
so it's where we look creatively that
we're going to be successful
okay councillor bright you have your
hand up
i think it was going to be for the
one great torrington website wasn't it
chris oh yes yeah
so yeah yeah however it will come as no
surprise mr
john eels uh is that hand worth wafting
around again
i'm sorry i no need for apologies
opinions are great
i'm just aware that uh actually uh
from what we see what i'm seeing from
within
town uh torrington has actually braved
the code
crisis remarkably well with its
you know the shopping that's been done
in town i have never seen town
fuller on some of the days i've been in
town i mean it literally has been having
and this hasn't all just been you know
people from
holiday home somewhere else this has
been locals actually bombing to shop in
town
and finding town and actually buying
their wares from town
and that's no pun included um it's just
a case of
you know if you look back six months
everybody drove to morrisons and that
was the end of life
they don't drive driving morrisons now
they come into the town and they
actually are spending
a lot of money certainly on the
groceries uh where they weren't before
i i can't help knowing what goes on in
the collections area and the antiques
and whatever
i'm hoping they picked up a bit of
business but from the outside looking in
and that's just the outside slightly
looking in i would sense that
actually trying to have held up better
than it was before
not even as well but actually better and
that's what i
say people who may be able to tell me
otherwise
i think one of the things that people
described to me as as
as i was walking around town when i came
to visit was that
there's quite a number of people that do
their shopping by coming into town
and just going between maybe five or six
shops and they've got you know the
bakery and news agent and they do that
sort of circuit which is a bit like
how parisian shop when you know that
like they shop on us
almost like a daily basis and uh
we've seen a resurgence of that
nationally actually in in terms of how
people shop and
you're you're absolutely right john you
know it used to be much
more focused on the supermarket but now
as we've started
porting those independents that's formed
as new habit
in people and so in many ways that's why
this sort of shop happy or
virtual high street thing where you can
go between all of these different places
virtually and
order everything from one place is
certainly an idea
and if not that then maybe there are
ways in which we can encourage others to
pick up perhaps
which is supporting all of those
different
independent traders ben the other point
about that is that's good for cutting
down on food waste
i'm aware that uh ian your
hand is up still is that from the
website comment earlier
yep unintentionally hand going down no
worries
all right so let's look at some other
things so so
i mean these are slightly this is
manchester actually so they
don't worry don't have to be manchester
but uh there's been a lot of really
interesting campaigns again
uh karen i'm thinking back to your
marketing group
uh you know if you think quite carefully
about your messaging
and your audience i think that's a
really really good start you know
it's uh great to have trails but it's
like who are they aimed at what do they
want to learn what do they want to know
um is is some interesting work that you
can do around that sort of stuff but
this is very bright
and uh and welcoming imagery from
manchester there
um aussie street has done some really
interesting work on vacant shops now you
don't have
loads of vacant shops it's fair to say
um
but those that you do so just just um
as as an example what austerity is doing
um
it's launched a thing called future
aussie street um
in its is the town council local
business improvement district
and they've got seven hundred thousand
pound grant um
from central government i think it is um
and they're basically using that to do
up
uh shop fronts to really sort of you
know spruce up the town a little bit
and to use that as use those those shops
as meanwhile space for new businesses
and i'm sort of quite struck by
uh torrington as a place that has um
some young people some of them may want
to start a business but really sort of
need the support to be able to do that
maybe if there are um you know places in
town that might support that sort of
views
um
so again this is about taking vacant
space but it doesn't need to be shops it
can be
above shops or anywhere really and i
know that there's
a consideration in in the plans for for
the globe
to do something around this as well is
using that daytime
you know work from home population to
um essentially prop up the economy of
the town so they're not just left at
home
they're also coming in and you know if
there's an ability to be able to social
existence but also
interact economically which is really
important with each other
and with the town in general for those
people that have been working from home
um if you've got kids and massively
sympathize for you it can't been easy
not everyone is going to be able to do
that forever so
if you're if you find that your employer
shuts the office
for some some places these things are
going to be really really important
those those employers downsize
um bill grimsey who used to be
the ceo oh no sorry
this is just a thing about community
wealth building which is just
um it's just it's something that's
happening in preston
it's the most famous example of it and
basically it's just this idea
that you take any of the money that's
being generated locally and you keep it
as local as possible
and the preston model works on these
four different
uh metrics the first the first is
essentially harnessing the power of
of of your all of your anchor
institutions to make sure that if
they're buying
they're buying it locally goods and
services localizing that spend
the second is about the workforce and
where you know this is really good
particularly for local authorities
uh but where you've got workforces that
you can sort of support it's really
about making sure
that they're skilled uh and that's
properly skilled up
you know they're paid correctly um and
then they
are encouraged to spend locally um and
save locally with
credit unions and that sort of thing um
the third is around
land property investment so again with
those anchor institutions local
authorities
how are they and we're seeing this
absolutely biddeford um uh
you know how are you using your land
how you acquiring land to make sure that
the economy
um keeps as much earth as possible local
um and then finally this idea of
economic
democracy um which is it's about
it's about governance basically so you
know what what you can set up in
governance terms
that help you give your citizens greater
investment in your economic future
but that so there can be a lot more uh
date
uh uh detail that i can send you on the
question model that's really really one
to consider
um bill clinton is just gonna say very
quickly he's
he's developed something called uh build
back better which is his sort of
recovery plan
um for towns and cities up and down the
country he's basically said
when our ceo of iceland when our ceo of
wix
we ruined the high street we did it not
really understanding what we were doing
um but you know sort of mayor copper and
what he's saying is
you now need this massive shift in power
away from central government
much more towards local communities and
having this
renewed focus on localism empowering
local people
helping them to understand how they can
design their own places essentially
um it is a fantastic read as well then i
would encourage anyone isn't it
interesting isn't it
regeneration it's not an arduous one
no it's great it will fill you with hope
for the future of your town
um and very much is based along a lot of
the conversations that we've been having
around uh community at the heart of
the the design around the importance of
the environment
the importance of uh independence
the importance of fun um and equally
kind of with things like
uh the globe the importance of community
ownership
and leadership so that's that's the
second one is absolutely
um reinforcing that idea that you people
as as
leaders need to be as empowered as you
possibly can
and i remember you know um so you were
saying this before about the
you know the idea that it feels like
it's always you but what you need to be
given is the power to be able to
inspire others to be able to help you um
achieve what you need to achieve for
your place particularly with that vision
in in in mind and then the third one
um your cars more green space now i know
rural communities are really reliant on
the car
um certainly maybe he's talking about
the cities a little bit more in terms of
that but uh um
you know the commons as an asset for for
for great torrenting you know i'm sure
that you would agree
it is something that would actually
bring people from far far away even if
they have to drive there
um so looked at work work clubs and home
offices
infrastructure things around superfast
broadband um what happens with
retail in terms of demand patterns you
know this is changing in all sorts of
different ways
and also we're talking a little bit
before about rural housing and how
uh you know how that's changed as well
um let's do our poll
chris can you launch the poll
fingers crossed it's like launching a
ship isn't it who knows it's gonna work
okay there you go right so what we're
gonna do what we just
what i wanted to do at this point um and
it's not you know massively
representative
uh it's just to get an idea about
you know essentially how personal habits
are changing local economies this is all
completely anonymous you won't see how
you voted
but what i'm trying to find out is how
many of you stopped online before the
pandemic
during lockdown and now so to understand
about you know whether those habits have
been retained i think we can learn a lot
from that
and it's also tells us about um
how those individual behaviors can make
a difference right
if you're coming in now two of we need
more of you to vote if you can
oh the votes are coming in thick and
fast
brilliant okay
right you don't all have to vote we've
got one that hasn't voted
you don't have to vote if you don't want
to
okay look let's end the polling really
useful thank you so
right this is the uh just going to share
the results here
um so so
75 of you did shop online before the
pandemic
interestingly enough as far as you're
concerned that went down a bit
um during lockdown um
i'd that'd be interesting to understand
if any of you've got any thoughts about
why why you you stopped shopping online
and if you did begin shopping online
during the pandemic
you have now continued to do so
um so that is interesting itself is
there any thoughts on why
their habits change during lockdown or
why they didn't change
no oh john uh you'll need to unmute
yourself
but the third question says if you began
shopping online during the pandemic do
you continue to shop
i didn't begin shopping online i was
doing it already so
the third question is not one that's
easy to answer
yes no absolutely you're quite right so
it's it's one of those things that you
yeah
if you if you were already shopping
online anyway or you'd never have
shopped online
and answer is different um adrian you've
got your hand up
yeah i think the um i did um about the
uh the second question
um in question really about where it
dropped a little bit
we had in my in my household um
because of lockdown um my wife for
example couldn't
couldn't therefore work has been being
self-employed
um so we had to dramatically tighten the
purse strings
so what from what we did online before
the pandemic
uh was really affected during the
pandemic
we're coming slightly coming out the
other side now but i don't know whether
what other people think but that may be
part of the reason why during the
pandemic actually online shopping
um possibly went down a little bit yeah
yeah it's really useful thank you and
ian you're on mute
yeah i seem to have my hand up from last
time but i can answer anyway
um again i've i've was um similar to
adrian i was um
at home working from home in lockdown
and i used to do well we still
still shop online but that seemed to
change during lockdown that
in the sense that i suppose i wanted to
support the local
trades the baker the butcher the the
green grocer and so on
so my my thinking is if they look
if i look after them they'll look after
me longer term
that kind of approach that's really
useful thank you
i'm not going to remember the actual
number of this person's deli and i don't
necessarily want to single him out but
one of the um really really champion
businesses
in uh in torrington that i discovered
was the one opposite the south
is it south side car park the the delhi
base yeah the 37
um where just to see a business adapt to
that extent doing lockdown to really
meet people's needs
was it did it did brilliantly for his
business
it did really well for his customers and
it there was a real sense
in talking to him that that actually
this was a mutually supportive
arrangement and i think there's a lot
can we learn from that
and ian do you your hand is still up do
you
and john you had your hand up before
didn't you
i did have my hands up um and i'm just
going to just just note the fact that
people might not have spent so much
during online during the actual
area of code because they haven't got
anything else to do
i they couldn't do the stuff that you
would normally do
do i want to take my camping gear out oh
i better get a new mac
all that sort of stopped yeah but there
was sort of less to spend your little
little bucks on so it's all
it's changed now you're always you know
everybody's gone back to doing what they
wanted to do basically
but at that time you were restricted of
eating food and drinking
you couldn't really go anywhere you
couldn't do anything you know you'd buy
a jigsaw now and again that was about it
yeah okay let's have a look at the
second poll that we've got
um let me just launch this so again this
is really about
um looking at sort of connections that
people have formed
and what i'm going to try and do is look
at this in the context of
sort of national trends and what what's
happened so
you may have seen some of those um
interesting
studies that uh that were launched sort
of showed
how people have changed in terms of
their social connections local
connections
during the pandemic so if you could vote
in this one what we're asking is if
you're shielding during lockdown are you
still shielding now
and most of you very clearly are not
shielding
um oh some of you might be um
that whole idea around people feeling
anxious about returning to the town
centre to shop
you know again that will have a huge
impact on whether people
choose to continue to
shop online um
there's we've got a question here about
whether you've made new social
connections are you volunteering more do
you got to know your neighbours more
maybe this is the sort of place where
you everyone already
knew their neighbors and then finally
this idea of about
this led sword about you know the
economy needs tourists but actually
you know they're coming in from all
parts of the country are they bringing
the virus with them you'd be you've been
sort of mercifully
um you've escaped as much as possible
the corinthian viruses so i can imagine
there'd be some worry there
um we've had eight out of
we've lost one we've had 10 out of 12
vote that's great
okay that's brilliant thank you so
this is the results of that
uh okay so we uh so one of you is still
shielding
um three of you aren't 64 percent
if you didn't shield seven if you didn't
shield um
interesting that there is still some
anxiety about people returning to the
town center
to shop not not lots i mean we lost john
again
um not a lot but it you know it's it's
important that that we recognize that
some people are still
feeling a bit anxious about about coming
back into town
91 of you have made new social
connections so that's really really
interesting to know
um even a town the size of torrington
you know who those social connections
were was that about more volunteering
um what what was it and then there's a
really interesting
even split uh
in terms of that and i think there's
there's a lot
so sorry i haven't shared the results um
that that uh
last question really even split so half
of you
are concerned about the risk of taurus
spreading favorite 19
and the other half of you is basically
saying
economy needs them okay so they're the
results does anyone got any
anything to say about the new social
connections they made
and uh what they think would mean for
sort of social interaction in the place
or any thoughts on that idea about and
it was it was really the the thursday
night clapping that
um was kind of amazing we live on castle
street which is just off the town square
and um although it we know
a lot of the neighbors to say hello to
we didn't necessarily know them by name
as such but
um the lady that lives opposite us
teaches dance classes
and um there's a another lady that lives
at the top of the street that is part of
the silver band so she used to play her
trombone
every thursday and then we'd have a
massive kind of blast of dance music
from rita
and we'd all be out in the street
dancing for half an hour
and it was it was just a great
atmosphere and when we stopped doing
that
we kind of really missed it but as a
result of that we've
we sort of talk a lot more to the
neighbours than we would have done i
think
um and we we all know each other's names
now which we didn't
i mean we've only lived here just over a
year and now we know the names of all
the people on the street
virtually um which we didn't necessarily
know before so that
that was a really good fun experience
for us we really
you know it kind of made us feel very
much part of the town
um being kind of newbies um so we we
really appreciated that
it's so interesting you know i really
think a lot can be built
from such humble beginnings in a sense
you know if you
if you understand who around you is more
a bit maybe a bit more vulnerable
if you understand you know the sort of
circumstances of people around you and
maybe it's you know
at some point next year you start with a
bit of a street party
and or you you know do a bit
volunteering together there's all sorts
of opportunities that can
it can come from that so it's really
really interesting to hear that
um anyone else have any thoughts about
this idea about
tourism and and what and what that means
for
people's concern
i think if i lived in some of the other
places that we see on tv i'd be very
concerned i think because we live where
we live
and i think there has been quite a good
level of responsibility
i think so and i think we're cueing
this distance the shots have sort of got
their things in
in place i i personally haven't i
thought i would
feel more unsafe but i haven't felt more
unsafe
um but i think there are certain parts
certainly like in well
not too far away where i'd be very
concerned because of just
like we don't have a nightlife really
which we've already discussed which is
you know a minus but one of the plus
results that might be that we haven't
had lots of
opportunities for people to get together
and maybe
you know feel that they weren't socially
distinct thing as they should
which we've seen across the country and
other places i think it's just because
we i think
the traders have done really well in
handling that and i think that's given
a sense of security really yeah okay
um so that's really interesting thank
you karen thanks to everyone that
gave gave us some comments there um
i we said before right at the start so
so this is really about so we understand
a little bit about how
people are behaving here um but what do
you think is
missing from what we've said so far what
do you really think is missing
in the town that might to to
help to meet those new needs that people
have got about
you know sort of encouraging people to
visit the cloud maybe in a socially
distant way
um but that and also in more general
economic terms what do you think is
missing that will help
um thrive a bit more
okay for jill hey
um i think then
sorry did you ask me yeah okay sorry
um i think that there are um there are
visitors coming but i don't think
there's necessarily much for them to do
um when i've been when i've been sitting
in the square sort of in the
um early evening they're definitely been
groups of visitors walking around but
there's
absolutely nothing nothing for them to
do there's nothing
open there's no nothing really that they
can go into
and i think during the day again because
um
because of the because some places are
still closed that again
if the weather's not so great there's
nothing to do i keep sort of accosting
people and saying are you a visitor and
i
um sort of chipping them towards the
view and on towards the commons if the
weather's nice
so that they know that they can wander
around there but there's not a lot else
other and not many other places for them
to to go to yeah because that's right
just quickly ask kind of
when you've been doing those um football
camps you say there's kind of visitors
milling around
would you also say that the same is true
for young people that there's not enough
for them to do and that there's
a lot of them milling around yeah there
are there's quite a few of them
i've been sitting just outside the town
hall and they've been under the town
hall
chatting and practicing dance moves etc
but yeah there's not a lot for them to
do at all either
so we've had visitors to the town and
i'm sure they've been spending during
the day but when it gets to sort of tea
time
they're having to go because you know
they're trying to wander around the
square but literally
you know there's been about five places
open yeah
i think if you look at all the facebook
groups recently there's been a number of
uh kind of restaurant requests put on
there
and it tends to be go to beaford go to
biddeford go to
woolsery rather than there's this great
place in central torrington
yeah anyway felicity i was going to say
exactly that about
the most common question we get asked is
is there somebody we could
somewhere we can have lunch or is there
someone we can have an evening meal
you know where would you recommend for
an evening meal and
they're in torrington itself in the town
there are very few options if none at
all at the moment
yeah i just looked at winkley tonight
saturday night
yeah john john b
one of my big frustrations generally in
the area from
coming a year ago is that problems and
restaurants tend to stop serving at two
o'clock
and don't start again until six or seven
and
i don't want to eat lunch at two o'clock
necessarily or start at one o'clock
i want to be able to go somewhere at
three or four or whenever
and that's a massive frustration for me
there's quite a few nodding heads around
the uh around the
various rooms there
we're effectively saying we want to
adopt a continental lifestyle right
uh i don't think it's too much to
to imagine that uh you know there's one
place in town that you could go out and
eat evening i mean
it you know the idea that you have to go
to the next town is
it's quite unusual actually
yeah it's orange and really good and it
does need a good restaurant
not necessarily a high class restaurant
you know good decent food for a good
decent price and i think that's
really lacking yeah this is interesting
because then
there's very clearly demand for it so
it's it's it's interesting to
to try to figure out why it's not being
met so the black course was the only
that was doing evening meals right okay
yeah
so that's that's currently closed and is
there
is then there's takeaways aren't there
but there aren't any restaurants at all
john the black horse stopped serving
lunch at two o'clock
when it was open but it was having
dinner as well right
i served dinner but you know that was
six or seven o'clock
there's a big void in in the middle
and that's not just torrington i found
that
well pretty common around the whole area
and i don't know many places i could go
to
i won in insto one at westwood hall
that would be open all day intriguing
and then you waved your hand a second
ago
uh yeah i was just going to say that we
went to the torridge for a tie last
saturday
um and okay you've got to walk down mill
street and back up with mill street but
it was very well organized excellent
food as always and
yeah it's it's open in the evenings um
so yeah
he's got a small restaurant at the back
of the pub and
you know so there's plenty of space and
he's organized it very well
and yeah the thai food there is is
stunning
so um it might be the only place to eat
in the evening but it's
stunning it's worth it yes definitely
yeah
very glad period okay good um
any other comments on any of that stuff
before we move on well there's a council
of right
that's right yeah um
so obviously we've all identified that
we don't have enough restaurants
to open for the evening so how do we get
them in
very good question i mean this is market
forces right i mean i
i would suggest that at some point
if the demand is there it will be met so
it feels to me as though the
circumstances around the black horse who
don't entirely understand them
but um but if there is demand there then
new landlords should be found pretty
quickly
um you don't look convinced about that
uh well i think it could be the issue
with the people owning the property
rather than
people wanting to get in their own
thought but um that's a whole different
ballgame really
but okay so if there are circumstances
around that
that maybe the town council or somebody
else can make
uh representations to those owners i i
don't know i mean
i i just don't know the situation but i
guess
i guess this is a basic point you know
maybe the globe at some point as well
but the basic point is that if the
demand is there then it should be met
um really interesting things happening
at the community all about state nights
and stuff
which would suggest that you know if
they if they're successful then maybe
it's
something that can be built on i'd also
suggest the momentum is important
um so people are more reluctant to open
a new business
where they feel that there's not
momentum in a place
so recently in torrington we've
obviously seen
the black horse um stop trading and
we've temporarily seen the plow um not
being active
and we've within kind of the usual
building
um we've obviously got the globe that's
shut and so it's a case of starting to
turn some of these
significant kind of blocks around
so i hopefully in not too distant future
we'll start to see some signs
um of the plow being able to open its
doors again
um we've spoken briefly earlier about
the fact that we're
trying to explore um creating a work
club so
shared workspace within central
torrington as well
said today that we have posted uh
online the community engagement survey
about the globe
to start getting people excited about
that project
so it's starting to get people talking
positively about torrington
again rather than just kind of go oh
turrington
of course the plow's not there the black
horse the globe
so it's really a case of
let's start smiling being positive and
get excited about the future
and people will get on board and we need
to have these conversations and get
people
get people moving forward
let's talk about moving forward so
i think i said before that what we're
doing with this action plan
and you know there's there's some time
left to contribute to it and contribute
ideas to it and everything
but what we're doing with this action
plan is really trying to fit in as much
as possible with strategic plans above
it in the hierarchy
um one of which is the north devon
recovery plan
um and i know that um obviously torres
district council is doing a lot as well
as as are the town council and just in
the very
short term um you know we've had in the
immediate recovery there's been the
grants and i've spoken to a number of
businesses that
for whom those grants have been real
sort of lifesavers over the summer
um we've seen some physical changes to
town centers i don't think we've seen
loads in torrington
uh but uh generally they're about sort
of helping
um hospitality businesses even the
economy of businesses to
spread out a bit where you've got tables
and chairs um
in the medium term um obviously the
globe is
is potentially quite big news for for um
torrington um and then there's
support um including these action plans
in fact
for you know businesses in general
um and then in the longer term there's
these sort of very broad
uh commitments towards this idea of the
sustainable inclusive economy this is
really about
understanding how you retain uh jobs in
the area
um that you know young people want to
stay in and can stay in
uh ensuring that people have got the
skills that they need to be able to take
on those jobs
um this idea about the net zero carbon
society um biodiversity gain and
environmental improvement
is really big and i know that there's a
lot of
talk about that in north devon in
general anyway and then there's the
third thing which is
around health and well-being of our
communities and and a lot of that is
also to do with
mental health um and um you know
reduction particularly in rural areas of
um social isolation so
when it comes to the action plans um
and and what what's happening in general
but also what you know what's happening
in
in torrington so there are a number of
different barriers to success and the
first
is really around uh infrastructure
so you know um we're looking at i
actually think you've got quite good
broadband um unusually for a rural area
um but uh transport buses is a real
problem
in lots of different uh areas in it how
can that be turned around
and make sure that there's a lot more
connection so getting people to
for jobs and that sort of thing and
training as well
and again you know the globe is a really
really good start um there needs to be
lots more connections with
uh educational providers in the area to
make sure that
uh um there's that sustainable inclusive
economy is built
uh lack of money is always a problem
it's only going to be more of a problem
and you know in those sorts of
situations um
you know through austerity and now you
know as we pay back the massive debt
um that that was borrowed during
coronavirus
um there'll be a lot more i think
need for people to sort of make those
changes locally themselves as much as
they can
um but i think there is some investment
in some of that infrastructure
um and then sort of local governments
and partnerships really politics with a
big and a small
p and you know sort of uh it's
great that there are local champions but
there's also needs to be
um a lot more people sort of stepping up
where they can
and where that governance has a lack of
vision and i'm not saying it does here
at all
um but that sort of agreement on the
direction of
of travel there it isn't there that's a
real barrier to success to success
um so yes
so when it comes to the action plans it
will pretty much have the time
um what i'm what i'm really keen to do
is just make it absolutely based on
evidence
um a lot of things have been said
a couple of times which really helped me
to understand
what's really important to the the
people of the town
um but where we can get evidence
together so
into for instance pedestrianization if
it's timed closure
of the streets in the evening it would
be very interesting to understand where
that's happened
in other places and what you know where
that's where that's worked and where it
hasn't worked every place is unique as
i've said but any evidence that we can
get that says
this is an idea for you to take forward
would be
useful i want it to be focused on the
community as much as possible and this
is not to say
that there's sort of no uh
responsibility at all any of the local
authorities but to have some
focus on what can be done locally is is
quite important
um you know when you look at what what
the plow has achieved locally it's quite
it's quite extraordinary and so much of
it is to do with who's involved locally
that's why i think it's really
interesting to look at that crowdfunding
community share um option for its
funding it's really interesting one
um as i said complementary to the
council strategies that we've looked at
already and then you know i hate
um not too challenging but i think it's
important that
rather than sort of always talk about
the same things over years and years and
years
maybe there are some opportunities to
challenge you a little bit in what
might be achievable in action but of
course
you can always completely ignore it uh
so yes that's uh that's it as far as the
action is concerned what we're going to
do now is there's a
period of time where i take away all of
the evidence you've given me again thank
you so much for
um participating in this really
appreciate it if it can go out on
um facebook channels both time council
and district council
and just it's because actually you get a
lot of interaction on those on those
comments pages
um if you've got some
ideas preferably ideas that you
have a sort of chance of delivering and
you can
take a hand in delivering rather than
wouldn't it be good if
if there's sort of no possibility of it
being delivered i would be delighted if
you get in contact with me and i'm very
very happy for these contact details
um to be put onto facebook uh and
and obviously people can see it anyway
but if he's recorded
um and we've got probably about two to
three weeks now
where i'm going away and i'm writing
these action plans there will be
opportunities for
you to give me ideas in the meantime but
as the draft comes in
it will go to chris versus the client i
know that he will disseminate it
and then you will have the opportunity
to say oh this is awful
this plan is not going to work or this
plan is gonna work and we're sort of
keen to take this forward um and then
we'll start to finalize it
at the end of october
yeah so i hate that chris over to you no
i just said
the crucial point is that this is not
the end of the conversation it's very
much a start
we've had lots of reports and
[Music]
investigations and discussions over sort
of
the years what we really need to create
and this is why
i thought it was important to get ben as
an external figure
is to look at it and go right actually
what can we be
what can we be trying to achieve
from an outside perspective so that
collectively can go right in a similar
way to in biddeford we've developed a
theory of change
around the future high sheet fund is it
time to have a really clear theory
for this is the change that we as a
community want to see
in great torrington and how do we draw
more people in and get
more excited so i think
when i post the video some hopefully
tomorrow the more we can get that out
the more we can start drawing more
people into the debate
get more people feeding into ben's
thoughts and
in line with what john was saying
earlier getting more people
coming and wanting to take
responsibility for the future of their
town
to support their community is just so
important um
so for now it's 8 o'clock thanks
everyone so so much
for getting involved i look forward to
seeing you all again in the near future
and let's get this debate shared many
thanks take care everyone
thank you bye